PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Hello everyone.
Let's try this one more time.
Welcome and thank you for
joining me for a special
Chrome Mobile Office Hours.
Today I'm going to be diving
into a bunch of great tools
that you can use as a web
developer to really build out
your skill set and make yourself
more productive in
the things that you're doing
when you're building for the
mobile web.
We're going to take a
look at some demos.
We're going to take a look at
some libraries and frameworks.
With that, why don't we
jump in and have a
look at some slides.
Today is the first part.
We'll be having our
second version
of this next Wednesday.
and we'll dive into some great
testing tools and a couple of
other devices and things
at that time.
But for today, we're going to
look at the development
environment that's important
when you're building great web
applications, and particularly
for the mobile.
It's really easy to go and just
hack stuff together with
Notepad kind of equivalents.
But really, we become much more
productive when we have
really solid tools.
We'll take a look at some things
that will remove some
of the authoring abstractions
or provide some abstractions
to what we're trying to write,
so that we end up not having
to deal with a lot of the
crazy or merging stuff
together and all that.
Then we'll move into some of the
frameworks and libraries.
Things that will help make your
life easier to get things
done and easier to be able to
handle some of the stuff that
you don't enjoy doing--
or somebody else has already
written it, so why bother
writing it again?
Next week, we'll take a look at
performance, testing, and
build optimization.
If you're looking for some other
stuff, there's a great
place there where you can check
out Paul's Tooling and
the Web App Development Stack.
That's a great presentation
that he's got online.
You can download that or pop
through those slides.
These slides will be available
online afterwards.
And as well, if you look there,
say right about there--
OK, well maybe it's a little
that way-- but anyways, if you
have questions as we're going
along, please post them to our
moderator queue.
And I'll do my best to answer
those questions as we move
through the day.
Let's first of all take a jump
into the development
environment--
things that you're using to
code, compile, to build, and
reload your pages.
I have a personal favorite
development environment.
And that's Sublime Text 2.
Sublime Text 2 makes my life
really easy in terms of
providing intellisense so that
I can go in and start typing
something, have it
auto complete.
It does it for not just HTML
and JavaScript, but if I'm
writing something for maybe App
Engine and using Python--
or maybe I'm using Java, or
whatever back-end languages I
want to be able to use--
all of that stuff
is right there.
Easy for me to be able to
go in, get access to,
run quick and easy.
In fact, let's just pop out of
here for a sec and I'm going
to bring up Sublime.
This is actually the
presentation that we're
looking at right now.
You can see that it's got all
of the intellisense that I'd
normally be looking for--
code coloring makes it really
easy to find stuff.
If I create a new file--
actually, I didn't
want to do that.
Let's say File, New and I'm just
going to save this as an
HTML file, demo.html.
Save this.
One of my favorite things
is the snippets.
I can actually just type in HTML
and Sublime has a snippet
already saved allowing
me to go in and fill
these things in.
It provides great tab completion
between the
different events.
You can go and add
these yourself.
You can grab others from other
developers who have already
created these things.
It's a great text editor.
I always forget the simple
syntax on stuff.
I could type, for
example, link--
because I want to add a CSS
style sheet in here--
done.
All I did was hit Tab.
It completed everything--
put my cursor into the right
place so that I could quickly
and easily be able to get in and
do the things that I want.
It's not for everybody, but it
does save a lot of time and it
works for the PC, it
works for the Mac.
Really easy to be able to go
and use, get access to it
without having to go and
do anything too crazy.
And I think to buy it,
it's about $25.
It's relatively inexpensive,
really easy to go
get your hands on.
If we pop back to the slides,
the other one that I really
like is an app called CodeKit.
And CodeKit--
you can do this with build
scripts, you could do this
with something like Yeoman.
I find CodeKit was really easy
for me to be able to just plug
into a bunch of my existing
projects.
But I think the developer of
CodeKit calls it, it's like
steroids for web developers.
I really like to think of it
as something to do all the
hard work for me.
Something to do all the things
that I don't like to do, that
I don't want to have to go in
and be like, oh, how do I do
this, or what do I need
to go to do that.
It will automatically compile
pretty much everything from
CSS, to SCSS, to Less, all
that kind of stuff.
It'll do JavaScript.
It'll do inserting
HTML into places.
That was a really great
tool that I found
worked really well.
It will also do JSHinting and
JSLinting, so that as I go
through and work on my projects,
it tells me when I
do something that maybe
I shouldn't be doing.
It's a quick, easy way.
In fact, if I bring up CodeKit
right now, you can see here's
the CodeKit for my mobile
tool belt project.
There's the slide config.
It doesn't import anything.
And it's not imported
by anything.
But I can check the syntax with
JSHint, and then I can
concatenate [INAUDIBLE]
any files that I need
to work with.
Couple of great little
things there.
Really easy to be able to go
and work with these guys.
I really like CodeKit.
I'd recommend that one.
It's only available for the Mac,
but I'm sure there are
other equivalent ones
for the PC.
Or you could really-- if you
wanted to be down and dirty--
you could write your own build
scripts to go and take care of
some of this stuff.
But let's dive into some of the
development tools, some of
the things that are worthwhile
using, worthwhile getting our
hands into, and making great
mobile websites.
One of the biggest complaints
that I've often heard from
developers is they often think
that, oh you know, it's this
mobile site.
It's got to be ugly.
It's got to be--
oh it's mobile.
There's so many devices to go
handle or there's so much
stuff, I just like, oh.
Don't let the fact that people
are saying, oh it's mobile, or
oh, it's enterprise, or
oh, it's the web be
an excuse for ugly.
That's just lame.
Beauty sells.
We all know that.
When you go into any store,
anybody who has a beautiful
product, you go, oh this is
pretty, I want this, right?
We want beautiful stuff.
Building a more lickable
mobile web is really
important, and something
that we should spend
more time on doing.
There's a couple of great things
that you can take a
look at for this.
Mobile Patterns and patterns.com
are two really
great sites that provide some
great examples, show what
other people have done,
and lay things out.
Let me pull one of these
up right now.
This is Mobile Patterns, but
you could see here's some
interesting ways on what this
company has done to provide
easy access to stuff
for messaging.
And one of the things I really
like about this, is they have
different ways that I can go in
and I can say, hey, I want
to see what people have done
for photo galleries.
I can see all sorts of different
photo galleries and
see what people have done to
create photo galleries.
I can get some ideas and I can
go and create some neat and
interesting concepts.
Maybe I want to go and figure
out what I think a pop-over
should look like.
Here's a big list
of pop-overs.
Patterns.com is very similar
in that it's got
lots of great examples.
You want to get an idea
what different
about boxes look like.
You can go through and you
can see all these.
Just to get good idea of how
should I make my stuff look.
It's a great place for you to
go get great inspiration.
But in inspiration, you still
need to follow some human
interface guidelines.
Both Android and Apple for iOS
have a really great set of
human interface guidelines.
But there's one thing I really
want to highlight here.
It's that, these are really
fantastic for
those specific devices.
It makes perfect sense for me to
follow the human interface
guidelines if I'm building
an app that's only
going to work on this--
on my Galaxy Nexus phone.
But if I build something that
follows the Android design
patterns, and somebody goes and
uses it on an iOS device,
or a Windows device, it's
just not going to fit.
It's going to feel awkward.
It's going to feel weird.
It's not going to feel right.
It's really important that we
follow through on some of
those different design
guidelines.
As well, there's some
really great stuff.
Apple has some stuff for
designing web content for
mobile Safari--
actually for not just mobile
Safari, but Safari in general.
If you're building for
web, they've got some
great content there.
And Microsoft even has some
really great stuff around
Windows Phone.
I'd recommend checking
out those.
But again, don't put too much
effort into making your app
look exactly like one particular
platform because
it's going to feel unnatural
on other platforms and, at
some point, they're probably
going to change the look and
feel of the platform
just a little.
And all of a sudden you're
going to look
awkward and out of date.
You don't want to duplicate
the other platforms.
I tend to like to start with
some of the boiler plates that
are out there, because I find
that they're really useful.
They each have different
purposes in life.
They each have different reasons
for being and trying
to solve different problems.
I think my two favorites are
jQuery Mobile and Bootstrap.
Bootstrap is the one that I
tend to use most often,
because I find it's
the most flexible.
Gives me the most ability to be
able to do things, whether
I'm building something for a
mobile website, whether I'm
building something for a desktop
website, whether I'm
building something that's
responsive and works in any of
those sizes.
But those are really important
to me, to be able
to have all of those.
Bootstrap has fantastic
responsive layout
capabilities, as does
jQuery Mobile.
Checking out both of those--
really good.
But now let's jump into some
of the more fun and
interesting libraries.
These are things that I think
are really helpful, that
reduce some of the pain that
we feel as developers and
really make our lives easier.
Fast Click--
the guys at the Financial Times
Labs have been doing
some phenomenal work over the
last couple of years, and have
really built a phenomenal
mobile web app--
the Financial Times Web App.
It's just absolutely fantastic
from a design and experience
perspective.
It works offline.
It feels and acts and looks like
a native app, even though
it's a web app.
And in fact, when you set it
up and when you install it,
they encourage you to add it
to the home screen so that
it's right there, easily
accessible, easy
to get access to.
You've got a quick way
to be able to go
and use those things.
But one of the things that they
found was there were a
bunch of mobile web bugs, or
there were things that didn't
behave like native
apps on the web.
And they wanted to fix those.
One of the first things that
they really started working on
was the Fast Click libraries.
And with the Fast Click
libraries, the problem that
they were trying to solve is
that on mobile devices with
touch screens, the
browser says, oh
you touched the screen.
Well, if you just touch
the screen, do you
want to drag something?
Or do you want to maybe zoom?
Or what are you going to do?
And so because of that,
it sits there and
it has a 300 second--
wow, 300 second delay would
be pretty crazy-- a 300
millisecond delay in
terms of until it
fires the touch event.
So we want to get rid of that
300 millisecond delay because
it really is awkward.
In fact, let me pull up a little
demo for you so that we
can have a look at
what's going on.
Here we go.
I've got my iPad up.
And so I'm going to bring
up this page.
And here's the Fast Click demo
page that the Financial Times
guys wrote.
This top box that you
see up here, box A--
box A doesn't use Fast Click.
Box B does.
Now, watch how long it takes for
the box to turn green from
when I touch the screen.
You're going to have to sort
of trust me to say, touch.
And it took awhile.
Touch--
and it takes that like
couple milliseconds--
well, 300 milliseconds--
from the time that I touch
until the time
that the event fires.
Now they've solved that
with a library that
they call Fast Click.
We've enabled Fast Click
on this box here, B.
Watch as I touch it.
Touch, touch, touch, touch.
It's almost instantaneous.
Touch, touch, touch.
By using this, you can make
your buttons, your touch
experience, feel much
more responsive.
And the reason that's happening,
like I said, is
that instead of looking for the
touch end, they fire on
the touch--
let me try that again.
Instead of listening for
the touch, they listen
for a touch end event.
When that touch end event
happens and the user hasn't
moved their finger from the
touch start, it fires the
touch event then.
Using this library
is really easy.
It's only a couple of K .
It's pretty small.
And if you gzip it and include
it in your library file,
really easy to go add.
But window.addEventListener, you
listen for the load event
and then just put a new Fast
Click on the body.
And that allows you
to go through.
It will go through and find all
of the elements on your
page that would register
a touch--
buttons, and other things.
And it listens for those.
One thing I did find in some
of my projects that I've
worked on, is that if you add
a button after the fact--
after you've run that particular
Fast Click document
body, maybe you're adding a
button to the DOM or something
to that effect--
then you need to go and just
add that Fast Click to that
particular element that gets
added after the fact.
It doesn't automatically go and
watch for new elements.
It only adds for the elements
that are already there.
It's a really great tool for
being able to make your apps
feel more responsive.
One of the big things that I've
often run into when I've
been trying to debug is that
there's no real console log on
the iPad and iOS devices.
They had it up until iOS 6.
They took it away in iOS 6.
And on Chrome for Android, or
even Android browser for
Android, you don't have access
to the debug console unless
you do any kind of
remote debugging.
Being able to figure out, hey,
what's going on in my console,
is a really useful thing to be
able to do so that you can
figure out, hey, what's
going on?
What's happening here?
Are things working?
Did I get to that point?
Are the values--
you guys all know what console
log can be used for, so I
won't continue on that
sort of thing.
But JSConsole is a really great
tool that you add some
code to your application, and
what it does is it captures
all of the console log events
and it pushes them up to a web
service, so that you can watch
up on that web service
what's going on.
Why don't we take a look
at that for a sec.
I'm just going to bring
up my page here.
And I've got a listener.
You can see here, all right.
And let's go to my iPad.
You can see here I've got
a listener started.
And on the iPad, I'm going
to start my sender.
As soon as I send that,
it pops up with a
little dialogue here.
Let's just make this a
little bit bigger.
The dialogue is a warning that
says, hey, I'm going to send
everything off to
another service.
Just a word of warning, remember
to remove this script
before you deploy this.
Go back.
I'm going to click OK on this.
And sure enough, you notice
a whole bunch of things
went and fired off.
What I did is in my application,
I actually have
it go and show me what the
screen width is, what the
height is, what the device pixel
ratio is, so that I can
understand, hey, what's
going on in my page.
And sure enough, I've got a
little loop that fires every
about two seconds or so.
Let me actually kill this
so that we can see
what's going on here.
But you can see that I've got
all of my remote console logs.
My screen available
width is 768.
My available height is 1004.
It gives me that insight into
what's going on with my
application.
It gives me the idea that, hey,
I can go and understand
this stuff.
Now, one thing to just a note on
this, is that once you use
a particular key, you
can't use it again.
Particularly, if you're doing
some testing, you'll use the
key, and it'll say OK,
great you've used it.
You try and use it again,
it's not going let you.
That's a security precaution
meant to make it easier--
meant so that if you do
accidentally leave the library
in there, you're not going to
leak sensitive customer data.
One thing to note in there.
Don't use this on anything where
you might have sensitive
customer data, because you
are sending all of your
console.logs over
HTTP clear text.
You're just sending them up to
somebody else's service.
And potentially, there's people
who could be listening
or doing not nice things
with those things.
Let's jump over to HammerjS.
Because if you're building
mobile web applications,
you're definitely thinking about
touch, because touch is
just one of those really cool
things that is really
important to be able to use.
And understanding--
touch, you tap something,
or something like
that, that's easy.
But if you want to be able
to handle gestures--
maybe you want to do drag to
delete, maybe you want to drag
to move something around
a page, maybe
you want to do anything--
handling those, you could write
it yourself, absolutely.
But why write it yourself when
someone else has already
figured out all the
intricacies?
They've figured out all the
little details on how to make
things work properly, make them
behave in the right way.
HammerjS is a great library that
you can use in order to
simplify some of these things.
Let's pop back to our
demo here for a sec.
Sure enough, let's bring
up HammerjS.
Here's my page with HammerjS,
and it says you can touch me.
If I scroll across.
It says dragging.
And it tells me when we're also
completed, so it's dragged.
I can tap--
single touch.
I can double tap--
you tapped me twice.
I can do a pinch zoom, so that
you can maybe zoom something.
It gives you a full set of tools
that you can quickly go
in and be able to understand how
you want to add things to
different elements.
You can drag, like I said.
It's a really powerful
library that's really
only about 2k in size.
It's really easy to include,
really easy to go add to your
applications, and it really
doesn't add a lot of work or
anything like that to go add.
I, a couple weeks ago, decided
I was going to add swipe to
delete gesture to one
of my applications.
And I found it really
easy to do.
I used the on drag
start to notice--
actually, no I didn't
use on drag start.
Let me rephrase that.
I used on drag, which fires
as you move across.
I used the on drag event firing
to change the position
of my elements.
That way, as you dragged
it across, it
moved across with you.
And then I used the on drag end
to check to see how far
the user had dragged the
event or the element.
If they dragged it past the 3/4
mark on their page, I said
OK, great you want
to delete this.
And I deleted the element.
But if they didn't drag it past
that 3/4 mark, I said OK,
no problem you obviously don't
want to delete this.
And I set the left
back to zero.
I also used a little bit
of CSS transition.
That way, the element swung
back in a nice maneuver.
Worked really well.
Provided a really great
user experience.
Lawn Chair is another great
library that I like to use.
It does a bunch of things
and normalizes
storage on the client.
One of the things that I've
often had a bit of a challenge
with is what different index and
data stores are available
on the user's device.
Well, does the device
have IndexedDB?
Does it have Web SQL?
Does it have local storage?
Does it have session storage?
Which one's best?
Should I use local storage?
Because there's been a whole
bunch of articles recently
saying don't use it because
it's really, really slow.
But then earlier this week,
there were a couple articles
that said, no use
it, absolutely.
It's really fantastic.
And the only time it's slow is
that very first read where
it's a couple of milliseconds.
Now, the one reason I would
recommend not using local
storage or session storage for
your applications is because
it's synchronous.
You can make it asynchronous
by wrapping it
in a set time out.
But most other storage
mechanisms that are available
for the web-- in fact, almost
every other storage mechanism
available for the web--
is asynchronous.
That means you're going to
go and say, get me this
information.
And then when you've got it,
call this call back and give
it this information.
By using something like Lawn
Chair, Lawn Chair's really
smart in that it goes, OK great,
you're telling me that
your preferred provider is
IndexedDB, but if you don't
have that, I should
use Web SQL.
But if I don't have that,
I can use local storage.
And if I don't have that, I'm
going to fall back to
something completely
different.
It gives you a really nice
fall back, an ability to
specify your preferred order on
which way things fall back.
That's one of the things I
really like about it, in that
it just gives you that real
easy fall back ability.
And it abstracts away all of the
implementation details for
each of the services.
You don't have to know, oh crap,
does it do this, does do
this, how do I do this?
It just works.
I don't have a demo for it
because it's not really the
most sexy thing to go demo.
Like ooh, look, I can
go store something.
Oh look, I can pull it
out of a database.
Really, that's one of those
things that, eh.
But when you do get it to work,
it's pretty awesome.
And it's a good way to be able
to go and grab access to some
of these things.
High DPI Displays is another
really useful one that I think
is definitely worth
mentioning.
Because there are a lot of
tools out there today, in
terms of how to go use those,
what you should do when you
need to use those, or
anything like that.
So there isn't an easy
answer today.
Lots of browsers are
working on things.
The W3C is working
on a standard.
But there are a couple
of options.
The first thing I want to
mention is using the--
sorry, excuse me--
using media queries in order
to go specify how you want
your images to be produced.
In this particular case, we've
got media-only screen and
minimum device pixel
ratio of 1.5--
1.5 being a high DPI screen, a
reasonably high DPI screen.
Great, go use this
as the image.
If you're not a high DPI, it
would go use something else.
There's a really easy way to
be able to go do those for
background images, or images
that are placed as
background on pages.
Image-set is the second one
and it's only available in
Chrome and Safari today
in WebKit browsers.
But I expect to see it coming
in future browsers.
That's the primary reason why
you see a vendor prefix there.
But with image-set, what you can
do is in your CSS, you can
specify, all right, well, here's
the URL to my image for
one device pixel
ratio devices.
But for other images, where
maybe it's 2x, 1.5x, whatever,
you can specify which image you
want it to use so that you
can say I want you to use the
1X, I want you to use the 2x.
So that's something that's
available today.
Again, that's specified in CSS,
so that's not going to
work beautifully well for images
that are dynamic or
images that are stored sort
of as actual image
tags on your page.
For documents that are stored
as images in your page-- let
me hide myself here so that
we can actually see
all the text here--
what this would be is using
the source set.
With source set, you can
actually specify different
images for different
properties.
It's kind of like using the
video tag where you have a
source element, and you can
specify different sources for
different properties.
Maybe you've got different
video formats or
something like that.
It's the same concept behind
source set on the image tag.
You specify here, I want-- this
is my high-def image,
this is my low-def image, and
what's going on from there.
A quick easy way to be able to
go and use those things.
For best practices on this,
there's a lot of things that a
lot of people are trying
these days.
The number one thing that I
would call out and say, that
image replacement--
using some of the JavaScript
libraries that people are used
to using to go and do image
replacement is generally
frowned upon.
It's a performance hit.
You start downloading one image
and then you go and
replace it, so you end
up downloading more.
It's just generally not
the best practice.
Instead, using vector images
and CSS styles for maybe
gradients or wherever you can
specify vector images,
definitely use that.
If you need to put images in
your page Boris Smus, one of
the guys on the Chrome [? dev ?]
team, has a great
article on HTML5 Rocks that he
compared taking a high DPI
image and compressing it a lot,
versus a high DPI image
that wasn't compressed a lot,
and compared the file size.
And actually found that it's
to our advantage as web
developers to use high DPI
images and use a higher
compression ratio.
They more often and than not
tend to be smaller in byte
size, but also end up being
as high quality or beyond
perception in terms of the
degradation in quality that
you're going to see if you take
a 1x image and you make
it twice as big--
as well, using some of the font
icons, or icon fonts like
Font Awesome and other stuff,
There's a couple of other things
I just want to point
out for today.
This and this are two very
different things.
If you think about your mouse
or a touch point on a mobile
device, they're very
different in size.
And depending on how you look
at some of these things, it
becomes a bit of a challenge.
Let's just pop over to
the demo for a sec.
When I first made this page,
if you look at some of the
text here, I had had just text
links as ways to get over to
different places.
But I found that it was
too small to click on.
Instead, I decided that, for
this particular case, it would
be better to use buttons because
they're easier to
click on, they're larger, and
for my mouse or for my finger,
a much easier thing to
be able to go use.
Avoid tables, relative
positioning, absolute
positioning, floats.
Headers and footers--
use position fixed so that it
goes up at the very top.
And if you want to do scrolling
inside an element,
set the overflow to scroll
so that it goes
to the right place.
And if you want the inertial
scrolling, like the stuff that
you're used to when you scroll
through on a native app, you
can add this WebKit overflow
scrolling touch.
And I believe this also works on
some Chrome Mobile as well,
in that it provides a really
nice scrolling experience.
I have couple of favors
to ask of you guys.
And if you have questions,
please be sure to post them in
the moderator.
The link's down there
at the bottom.
But my big request is,
help support your
local open device labs.
We need more of these.
There are so many devices out
there that people are using.
And to be able to, and need to,
test your devices across
that plethora of different
devices around the world, we
need more people to
help support them.
If there's not one in your
community, start an open
device lab or find
somebody who can.
If you have older or unused
devices, donate those to your
local device labs.
Here in New York, there's
one in Brooklyn.
Hopefully we can get one started
here in Manhattan
sometime soon.
But donating your devices to
these labs so that they can
have more devices to test on.
So that when you need to go
and test your app on a
particular screen or a
particular device, that device
is available to you.
You can go get it.
You don't have to go and
figure out ah, crap,
where can I do this?
How can I test this?
You have a great set of devices
that you can use.
Finally, we need your help.
Don't accept the status quo.
Don't accept that
the mobile web--
it's OK for it to look crappy.
It's in our hands as
web developers to
make it look better.
If you find bugs with Chrome--
Chrome for Android or
Chrome for iOS--
go to new.mcrbug.com and
tell us about it.
Let us know.
If there are things that bug
you about Chrome for iOS or
Chrome for Android, go see if
there's already a bug there
and star that bug.
We look at those stars to know
how many people this is
affecting and how many
people are really
passionate about this.
Build some mobile Chrome
experiments.
There aren't a lot of them there
today, but this is your
opportunity to go build
something cool that's just
neat, that works amazingly well
on the mobile web, on
mobile devices-- whether that's
a tablet, whether
that's a phone.
And submit them to
m.chromeexperiments.com.
Start an open device lab in your
area like I mentioned.
But the mobile web really
is what you make of it.
As developers, it's our
responsibility to build beautiful.
We can build crappy but that's
not fun and nobody's going to
enjoy that.
Building beautiful, it
really is up to us.
With that, I want to thank
you guys very much.
I'll open it up to a couple of
questions now, and see what
you guys are thinking
and go from there.
So one of the questions that I
saw earlier on our YouTube
comments was somebody wanted
to know, oh hey, I
don't have a Mac.
Can I still do some of this
mobile web development in
terms of using CodeKit, using
some of the other stuff?
You can't use CodeKit
unfortunately, because it is
Mac-specific.
But Sublime, you can
absolutely use.
It's available for Mac,
Windows and PC.
You can get equivalent apps.
I don't think I've seen any
personally that are equivalent
to CodeKit, but I'm sure
somebody's got one somewhere.
I'd check that out.
All right.
I think that's about all the
time we have for today.
I want to say thank you very
much for joining me, and I
hope you learned something
interesting.
Next week, we're going
to be diving into
testing on mobile devices.
This is a really interesting
piece because, how do you do
remote debugging on
a mobile device?
How do you do debugging when
you're trying to figure out
how does this work?
We'll try and take a look at how
to remote debug on iOS, on
an Android, Chrome
for Android.
As well potentially, if we have
time, we'll try and look
at Firefox and Opera.
All of those guys have mobile
remote debugging available.
We'll try to take a look
at some of those.
And we'll dive into some
emulators and other things
that you can do to really take
your device and mobile web
development to the next level.
So with that, I want to say
thank you very much.
Hope everybody has a
wonderful day, and
thanks for joining me.